Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome to 'Try. Die. Repeat'!
A game where you get success,
by standing upon the corpses of your fallen friends.
and I said "that sounds like a game just for me!"
So, I'm gonna give it a go!
Actually, I'm pretty sure that's what it is.
Hello?
(Robotic game-y voice: We are Evil Labs
*whisper* Mark: it's the Illuminati.
Game: The biggest corporation on the planet
Mark: Oh god..
Game: We do test to improve the life of all living beings.
Game: Recently we received an opportunity to perform an experiment with our prisoners.
Game: The Cubers.
Game: However, they must fail at our primary test
Game: Only then we will have the permission
Game: To do whatever we want
Mark: Okay?
Wait-
I-
I completely misunderstand what you're talking about here.
Oh!
OH! Look at the diversity that you have in this program of yours.
I'm sure this is gonna go WONDERFULLY for them
and they're not gonna DIE-
In horrible, horrible ways-
Am I playing now?
Is that me?
Dat me!
Oh, it me!
Oh dat me!
I'm so adorable!
Aww, I love the pixelated style-
OH, that's cute!
Man, I wanna play Slimer again.
Game: Welcome to our lab Subject Number 1
Mark: OKAY
Game: Do not be afraid. We don't bite.
Mark: I have a funny feeling you're lying
Game: L.O.L. At least will you be useful to Subject Number 2
Mark: What?
Game: And for us
Mark: Well how did that kill me?
I'm oh well all right then
How did that kill me?
Was it just to much of a fall? We got ninja-man coming up on the back end?
Ok we made it
Are those spikes? Those are spikes *HUAECK* Oh geez
So this is what the games all about, you can only progress by dying horribly.
Which is wha, is what I'm the best at.
So as long as I'm able to die continuously I'm gonna be able to complete this game
KABUSK- oh
Game: You've made it.
Mark: I-
Game: Now the real fun starts.
Mark: Oh.
I thought that was the end of the level. Oh, ok.
Oh, what is this? Is it booze to make me forget my tr-
Game:  If he isn't tiny enough, you already know what to do.
Do I?
Awwww, it was poison!? OH!
OHhhh
Oh, that's a sacrifice.
Wow, I can push around their corpses to-
HEEYAH! Missed me
WOAH aw...
The red means dead!
Ohhhh, I should've at least gotten that corpse a little farther in.
Oh, I messed up there.
Alright, come on.
Oh, geez
what? oh, oh geez AHH
Game: If I win a dollar each time that you died, I would be rich
*scared sounds* oh geez!
OH GEEZ SCOOB! AHH
Aww, come on! I had that, I had him!
Woah, hey pretty princess, how're you doin'?
Aren't you a tall drink o' water?
I think those compliments are for two different people but- AHHHHHH
Bastard! Well there goes the pretty princess, nice and dead
Heeeh! This time we're gunna get it *boop*
HEYAH oh this is- AHH fucking cock!
Game: How these tubes withstand so many of you
Mark: I, I don't know, I'm pretty terrible at everything so you better send- OAHHHHH
Well, I, I, ah, at some point I'll just be able to walk through all this
YAY! Checkpoint! AHH!
Okay. Well, dead now, that's good.
Oh good, another one.
Aww, well how am I supposed to be able to- ohhhh no.
Game: What time is the party?
Game: Oh (wha), never mind (*grunting angrily*), you're already dead
Mark: Yep, pretty much
Oh, nurse, you can help resurrect these poor souls
Aww, but I don't wanna!
Oh, man, if I go for that poison bottle I'll have to die anyway because- OH COME ON
All, right you silly bitch you come over here
HEUH I can't go for that
We don't have enough boooodies *laughing* We need mooore bodies!
Oh, this is, this has some bad implications here.
Game: Just do it
Mark: 'Just do it'? Okay. GOODBYE!
EEEEAH! Oh, no that's not gonna cut it
*HEUH*
Oh, I'm not going to be able to be able to get back up, I might have just boned myself
I guess I could have died up here and that would've been-
OHHH that would've been much smarter! I was a big old dumb!
OH I had unnecessary casualties. Oh don't trust Markiplier for anything!
I'm never gonna do- AH!
I'm never gunna do anything right, forever and ever, as long as I ever live
God dammit!
Okay, this time I'm not gunna be a fool and be betrayed by the fog of war
*ehhh* *ehhhh*
Okay, we're good, we're good, we're good, we're good, dammit!
*nghhh*
I mean eventually, I'ma run out of poison then I'm not gunna be able to do anything about this
Game: We will need a bigger coffin
Mark: Well, stop talking about my coffin, this guy is gunna go the distance
This is back to the original guy, I think they're just getting resurrected again.
*AHHHH* we made it!
*WOOOO* we made it. I thought that was going to smash down on us
All right, another one of these
oh, oh geez, oh geez, *AHH* aww man, I'm going to line up the corpses here!
*AHHHHH* ah shit
Game: You again
Game: How this is possible
Mark: 'How this is possible' in- aw, I wasn't even paying attention.
What, are, are you wearing, are you wearing a thong on your face?
Are you thong-face McDickFucker?
Ohhhh, you dick.
*annoyed groaning*
He's a survivor, HE'S A SURVIVOR
We got 'em, we got it, we got it good
Game: Wait, you should return
Game: This is the wrong path
Mark: Ohhhhh, did I discover
Game: Do not go in there, please
Mark: oohhh, OOOHHHH Oh what if I do? Probably just going to kill me in some other way
HELLO.?
Game: Okay, now we have a situation here
Mark: It is the Illuminati
Game: Activate the protocol or you end, now (*Mark groaning and sighing*)
Mark: YESSS
NOW WE SHALL TAKE OVER THE WORLD
SOMEHOW
DON'T KNOW HOW
BUT LET'S DO IT
*dramatic music*
* evil look*
oh! hi! Who the hell are yoooou?
*sirens* okay, wooah, oooh, okay, not what I was expecting
Shit, you gotta die. Oh, we gotta go. We gotta go and you gotta die
oh, this ain't good *eeeh* *huoo* *heeeeh* FUUUCK
We gotta go and you gotta die. *woap woap woap* *eeh* *eehhhh* boink
okay so we can't jump anymore, for some reason gravity got revoised (reversed)
*eah* *eah* (singing)  OHHH who's a winner? OHH
AwwwwWWW
Not me! I'm not a winner, don't, don't pin any metals to my chest I am a suck
FUUUCK! *assorted gibberish*
Yeah, that's more like it. Oh, get out of here
You don't need nothing, I'm running out of time, aren't I? *hebuh*
They didn't expect me to die this much you coulda gone though this on one go
*high-pitched sounds*
There we go, got it, nailed it, won it, did it, I'm awesome WOAH!
I don't know how that worked!
*8-bit John Cena theme plays*
I don't know what exactly that portal went to that it would kill the giant mecha-Illuminati but we did it
we saved the world, we preserved freedom throughout all the land
ALL HAIL ME and my infinite clones that don't look anything like me
Okay, so that was 'Try, Die, Repeat' which was what I think the name of the game was
and that was pretty cool, I liked that a lot
So, thank you everybody so much for watching, let me know what you thought in the comments down below
and if you got more indie games like this let me know, I want to play them
I definitely want to play these cool little mini-stories of games
they're really fun
So, thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you, in the next video! BUH-BYE!